>> Tucker: FOX NEWS ALERT
TONIGHT, THERE HAS BEEN A HITCH
AND HIGHLY ANTICIPATED COUNT IN
VIRGINIA GOVERNOR'S RACE.
FAIRFAX COUNTY THE BIGGEST AND
MOST DEMOCRATIC COUNTY IN THE
STATE OF VIRGINIA WILL NOT BE
SUPPLYING ITS VOTE RESULTS ON
TIME.
WE WERE SUPPOSED TO HAVE EARLY
VOTE AFTER 7:00 EASTERN BUT AN
HOUR AGO FAIRFAX COUNTY OFFICIAL
ANNOUNCED THERE IS A DELAY AND
THEY NEED TO RESCAN THE BALLOTS.
THEY WILL RELEASE PARTIAL VOTE
OF EARLY VOTE IN PERSON SOMETIME
THIS EVENING.
WE WILL BE TRACKING THAT FOR US
AND ALSO TALK TO BRIT HUME TO
FIGURE OUT HOW MANY VOTES THEY
NEED APPARENTLY.
GOOD EVENING, WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
EXACTLY ONE YEAR FROM TODAY IS
THE CONGRESSIONAL MIDTERM
ELECTIONS.
TONIGHT, THE GOVERNOR'S RACE IS
IN DEMOCRATIC STATES MAY GIVE US
A PREVIEW OF WHAT COULD BE TO
COME.
IN NEW JERSEY COME AT THE POLLS
HAVE JUST CLOSED, PHIL MURPHY
DECLARED HIMSELF KING OF THE
LONG-SUFFERING REPUBLIC FACES A
SURPRISINGLY SHARP REPUBLICAN
CALLED JACK CIATTARELLI.
IT SEEMS IMPOSSIBLE MURPHY CAN
LOSE WHERE THE ENTIRE VOTE, A
MILLION DEMOCRATS REGISTERED
WITH THE REPUBLICAN.
BUT DESPITE THOSE NUMBERS, HE
MAY COME CLOSE AND THAT WOULD BE
A DEEPLY OMINOUS SIGN FOR THE
PARTY OF JOE BIDEN CURED THE
OUTCOME OF THE RACES
IMMEDIATELY.
AND THEN THE COMMONWEALTH OF
VIRGINIA PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED,
THAT IS THE MOST CONSEQUENTIAL
ELECTION OF THE YEAR.
TERRY McAULIFFE ONCE THE
GOVERNOR OF THE STATE, HE RAN
AND WON EIGHT YEARS AGO AS A
MODERATE.
PROBE DID BUSINESS DEMOCRAT AND
DIDN'T HAVE TIME AND WON BIG.
HE'S BACK BUT McAULIFFE TO RUN
FOR VIRGINIA AGAIN BUT THIS TIME
HE'S IN A NEW MAN.
LIKE SO MANY IN THE SOCIAL
CLASS, TERRY McAULIFFE HAS
GONE ROGUE.
EQUITY, DIVERSITY IN THE
RACE-BASED POLITICS OF
EVERYTHING.
IF YOU WEEKS AGO, McAULIFFE
SAID HIS PARENTS HAVE NO
AUTHORITY OVER THEIR CHILDREN.
MOST SCHOOLS IN VIRGINIA WILL
FORCE YOUR KIDS WITH RACIST
PROPAGANDA, AND THERE IS NOTHING
YOU CAN DO ABOUT IT.
IF YOU COMPLAIN, YOU ARE A WHITE
SUPREMACIST.
McAULIFFE SAID THAT REPEATEDLY
ON TELEVISION I MEANT IT.
TO UNDERSCORE THE POINT,
TERRY McAULIFFE APPEARED AT
HIS FINAL RALLY LAST NIGHT WITH
HIS OWN ACTUAL CONSTITUENTS, THE
HEAD OF THE COUNTRIES MOST
TEACHERS UNION RANDY WEINGARTNER
WITH THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
LIKE TERRY McAULIFFE, RANDY
WEINGARTNER UP FROM VIRGINIA AND
NEVER HAD CHILDREN IN PUBLIC
SCHOOLS.
IN THAT WAY, IT WAS A PERFECT
MATCH.
HERE IS PART OF WHAT SHE SAID.
>> WE KNOW WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
TERRY McAULIFFE WAS GOVERNOR
IN THIS STATE.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
WE KNOW HOW THINGS TURNED AROUND
IN TERMS OF THE ECONOMY.
IN TERMS OF PEOPLE BEING SEEN
AND RESPECTED.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
WE KNOW ALL OF A SUDDEN THAT
PEOPLE WERE HEARD, PARENTS WERE
HEARD, TEACHERS WERE HEARD.
SPEED WHEN SHE'S A LOT OF FUN.
WOULD YOU PUT HER AT THE PODIUM
IF SHE WAS NOT PAYING YOU?
NO, COURSE NOT, NOBODY WOULD.
BUT LISTEN WHAT SHE SAID.
UNTIL TERRY McAULIFFE WAS THE
GOVERNOR EIGHT YEARS AGO,
CERTAIN PEOPLE IN VIRGINIA WERE
NOT "SEEING AND RESPECTED."
IN OTHER WORDS THIS STATE WAS A
RACIST AND THEN, THANK GOODNESS
TERRY McAULIFFE, BILL
CLINTON'S HATCHET MAN FROM
UPSTATE NEW YORK ARRIVED AND
LIBERATED THE PLACE.
TERRY McAULIFFE IS VIRGINIA'S
ABE LINCOLN PIER THAT IS WHAT
THEY ARE TELLING YOU.
IT IS HILARIOUS.
THE MOST FAMOUS POLITICAL EXPERT
A GUY AT A LOCAL COLLEGE
EXPLAINED THAT ONLY BIGOTS
OPPOSE ABE LINCOLN.
>> THE OPERATIVE WORD IS NOT
CRITICAL AND IS NOT THEORY.
IT'S RACE, WHAT A SHOCK, RIGHT?
GREAT SPEAR THAT IS WHAT
MATTERS.
THAT IS WHY IT'S STICKS.
YOU CAN CALL IT WHITE BACKLASH,
WHITE RESISTANCE, WHATEVER YOU
WANT TO CALL IT.
IT HAS TO DO WITH RACE.
>> Tucker: WHITE BACKLASH FROM
A WHITE RESISTANCE, WHITE,
WHITE, WHITE, EVIL, BIGOTED.
THAT IS THE CASE INCLUDING THE
EXPERTS ARE MAKING FOR
TERRY McAULIFFE.
CALLING THE OTHER GUY A RACIST.
THEY ARE SAYING THAT BECAUSE
ELECTION SEASON, THAT USUALLY
WORKS FOR DEMOCRATS.
WHAT IS INTERESTING COME IN THIS
CASE IT IS NOT WORKING.
GLENN YOUNGKIN A REPUBLICAN
CANDIDATE IS NOT A RACIST.
HE IS A CHRISTIAN, A DECENT
UNCOMMONLY GENTLEMAN APPEARED
TOO GENTLE FOR POLITICS MANY
ASSUME.
OVER THE PAST FEW WEEKS, GLENN
YOUNGKIN HAS MADE A POWERFUL AND
MOVING CASE WITH AMERICA THAT
MOST PEOPLE STILL WANT.
A COLOR-BLIND AMERICA WHERE ALL
IS JUDGED WHO WE ARE AS PEOPLE
AS INDIVIDUALS UNDER GOD AND NOT
FOR HOW WE LOOK.
AS A MEMBER OF SOME GROUP.
THAT PATIE